im moment spricht der pressesprecher des
gerichts platz oder schalten wir mal
kurz daran zusammen freiheitsstrafe
verurteilt und dabei die besondere
schwere der schuld festgestellt
nach den feststellungen der kammer hat
die angeklagte am frühen morgen des
dritten septembers
2020 den entschluss gefasst zunächst die
anwesenden fünf kinder heimtückisch und
sich anschließend selbst zu töten
hintergrund dieses entschlusses war der
zerstörte lebensentwurf einer
vida-vorsitzende sagte großfamilie auf
einer insel sowie die tiefe
erschütterung über den endgültigen
verlust des ehemannes und vaters der
vier jüngsten kinder
in umsetzung dieses entschlusses
mischte die angeklagte
verschiedene medikamente in
unterschiedlich hohen dosen in die
frühstücks getränke der kinder nach
einnahme dieses
medikamentencocktails wurden die kinder
wie von der angeklagten und von der
kammer festgestellt beabsichtigt
schläfrig so dass sie in der folge
einschliefen
die angeklagte habe danach im badezimmer
eine typische situation des badens
vorbereitet wasser in die wanne
eingelassen war das spielzeug
bereitgelegt sowie einen mobilen
heizlüfter aufgestellt welchen sie auch
in betrieb genommen habe
zur überzeugung der kammer
brachte sie dann das erste kind in das
badezimmer entkleidete es um es
anschließend im wasser zu ertränken
dieses wie der vorsitzende sagte
furchtbare vorgehen wiederholte sie vier
weitere alle an den anderen kindern bei
den
tötungen nutzte sie bewusst den durch
die verabreichung des
medikamentencocktails
herbeigeführten dämmerzustand der kinder
aus
die kinder bettete sie nach den
jeweiligen tötungshandlungen zurück in
die betten dabei legte sich die vier
kinder des ehemannes und vaters in
dasselbe bett
die kammer ist bei ihrer beweiswürdigung
davon ausgegangen dass die angeklagte
täterin dieser handlungen war dies
folgte mit blick auf das objektive
spuren bild unter anderem die
auffindesituation der leichname sowie
die situation im badezimmer und
desweiteren
aufgrund der whatsapp verläufe sowie des
weiteren verhaltens der angeklagten im
internet die von der verteidigung
ins feld geführte behauptung ein fremder
mann habe die tötungshandlungen
vorgenommen sah die kammer als
unglaubhaft und damit als widerlegt an
bereits die angaben welche die
angeklagte im ermittlungsverfahren
getätigt habe sein unkonstant
widersprüchlich und lebensfremd gewesen
die feststellung der besonderen schwere
der schuld
hat die kammer mit blick auf das gesamte
tatbild und die täter persönlichkeit
getroffen und dabei insbesondere
berücksichtigt dass hier vier kinder
leben vernichtet war fünf entschuldigung
muss ich noch mal machen
die feststellung der besonderen schwere
der schuld hat die kammer mit blick auf
das gesamte tatbild sowie die täter
persönlichkeit vorgenommen und dabei
insbesondere berücksichtigt dass hier
fünf kinder leben vernichtet worden sind
dieser fall war ich damit so gravierend
von gewöhnlichen mordfällen ab dass eine
aussetzung der lebenslangen strafe nach
15 jahren auch bei günstiger prognose zu
gunsten der angeklagten als unangemessen
erschienen
die kammer ist bei ihrer rechtlichen
würdigung davon ausgegangen dass das
verhalten der angeklagten als
heimtückisch zu bewerten war
insbesondere konnte die kammer die
überzeugen ja wir gehen raus
erschütternde details muss man sagen
nach diesen prozess nach dem urteil in
dem fall von christiane kadi september
vergangenen jahres fünf ihrer sechs
kinder getötet hat die höchststrafe
dafür lebenslange haft und eine
besondere schwere der schuld oder sie
nie wieder in freiheit sein wird